you know I saw trailer for this movie
and I was wondering why they didn't
release it in 3d like that would be
crazy if they released it in 3d right it
immerse you more No
you release this movie in 3d in theaters
uh sure 'z have one job and that is to
mop vomit that's what it is now so I get
it
hardcore Henry so hardcore Henry is a
movie those films completely in first
person like from beginning to end this
is a first-person action movie long
story short the movie starts out Henry
wakes up on the table he's been
reconstructed and he now has to go on a
quest a first person action quest to
save his girlfriend from an [ __ ] the
gist of it and this is a unique
experience for a movie absolutely you
can't even deny that like the movie hate
the movie unique is the word that you
would choose to describe it this is what
this movie reminded me of hardcore Henry
reminded me of crank
if crank was filmed in the first person
had a lot more action a lot more
shooting a lot more hand hang combat a
lot more killing so basically the first
person action video game you think the
movie is in that the movie is really
light on character I mean really the
only characters that you know and get to
know in the movie is Charlotte so
Coakley who once again is awesome dude
was great in this movie I think he's a
good actor he's a great actor and most
anything I've seen him in this is no
exception but really Henry has nothing
Henry has no real characters no real
depth his motivations very simple like
woman I love has been kidnapped got a
safe woman I love but I get why they did
it that way because Henry is you Henry's
me Henry's anyone who's watching the
movie the movie being in first person
that you're supposed to be projected
into the movie as Henry so when you give
Henry too much backstory and you put
them in a box Henry it's harder to see
Henry as you now granted the argument
stands Rose like all first-person video
games do have their main character who
have more character than Henry has so I
don't want to say that's just my
assessment I believe that's why they
didn't give Henry a lot more character
than they gave Henry that's like me
saying the Sun is bright like it or hate
it that's just the assessment of the Sun
but the action is pretty solid
especially by the end everything levels
up in here and that's how you know it's
inspired by video games there's actually
a mission in this movie where Henry has
to take out a building full of troops
this elevator is slowly going down it's
open elevator has someone in it so it's
like all right Henry
take out air all the baddies but don't
let them hurt the guy in the elevator I
mean that's video game 101 take out all
the bad guys protect the one guy don't
let them hurt him I mean I've seen that
in a hundred
video games the action does get jarring
at times I mean when the intensity is
coming at Henry and Henry is looking
that way looking that way grabbing guns
hitting people stabbing people really
just do this and then do that and know
that actions happening around you it
gets a little jarring you're like ah
okay that's why this movie's not in 3d
but it is go world they've built in
hardcore Henry I don't know when this
movie takes place I imagine it's in the
near future sometime this century but I
thought it was cool I don't want to tell
you too much about what is in this world
but you can tell I mean this sequel is
probably going to have more of what you
saw glimpses of in here and it probably
isn't going fun time and that's what I
can say about this movie this movie is a
fun time a fun time that is not for
everybody if you enjoy video games and
you enjoyed the movie crank you like
that kind of adrenaline intensity this
is your movie man you have fun it's a
unique experience I put you in the first
person of a revenge quest and that's
that road scene that you've seen in the
trailers that was my favorite scene in
the movie it's a ridiculous time that's
also a fun time you know your taste in
movies if you assess that this is your
thing you go watch this movie I will say
hardcore Henry is a great time no
alcohol required alright guys so
hardcore Henry have you seen it what did
you think about it or what's your
favorite ridiculous action movie out
there we're talking favorite ridiculous
Terminator 2 is not ridiculous friends
it's not it's real whatever you think
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you